Rob you just saw a game called apex
legends which is another battle royale
game but it is by a studio that we we
love right titanfall 2 is one of my
favorite games of all time
so respawn is responsible for a new
battle royale game what do you have what
do you think well it's definitely not
what I wanted from respawn in a way I
had to kind of shake off those feelings
but by the end of my play session I
played for about god I don't know maybe
4 or 5 hours of this game I came around
to liking it I'm actually not a big fan
of battle royale mmm do you played
blackout or I for denied her I yeah I
played them all I've just fallen off of
all of them
I you know I prefer titanfall 2 as far
as like you know quick matches just come
more clear-cut expectations I guess you
could say but that being said what's
here is its you know what what is it
it's team-based so there are 20 teams of
three and it's extremely squad based the
other thing about this is that within
your team you pick in beginning I showed
like you know character there's like
eight characters there will that all
have abilities right a passive ability
your standard tactical ability which a
lot of them carry over from titanfall to
so it's like phase dashing is that its
own kind of siphoning off into a into a
character is this in the titanfall 2
universe it is it's not a sequel to
titanfall 2 they said thirty years later
as I guess a timeframe but that being
said I find it I find it kind of bizarre
just to even say that because it doesn't
necessarily look and feel like that
hardcore grit of Sipho so I find that
was in titanfall to you know I mean like
there's a lot of colors a lot of I guess
you'd call it whimsical style too like
the characters deadbolts you had a lot
of well titanfall intent both you had a
lot of containerized houses and like
gritty backwater kind of design so
you're saying this feels a little bit
different yeah a little cartoonish
been training all day so it's about time
that you know we do some fighting
there's two things actually
you also had mentioned that seem very
different between this and Titan vol 2
which is one of them you might notice
right away but there's no wall running
yeah there's no wall running and there's
no no Titans then Titans
yeah which is weird the Titan thing no
Titans is kind of hard to defend I feel
like I granted I didn't ask them about
it but we did ask about why wall running
you know something that I loved in that
game you know entire ball - a really
great way of cheating death right here
they said that in their in their testing
of this game and the genre in order to
preserve the tactical elements of a team
wall running just they said may made it
so messy like they were basically
explaining that like it kept separating
people away from each other
it was hard to like follow another
teammate so that's the other thing about
this game that I want to talk about that
I find that it innovates the genre and
arguably innovates like on team play in
general is that it's got this really
easy-to-use fantastic ping system so
you'll see it in a few occasions we're
playing on PC so the right third mouse
button the scroll you click it and you
can just ping and use it in a variety of
ways I can ping ammo weapons say hey
there's a you know there's an EVA
shotgun here
hey here's ammo for heavy weapons here's
the scope even further you can go into
your own menu your inventory and click
anything there and be like hey I don't
have a scope on my sniper rifle hey I
don't have I need more ammo of this type
let'em oh here I say we move this week
and there's this further stuff I you
know just like Battlefield you can see
enemies who ping them and you're
essentially spotting enemies really
quickly and honestly we you know there
are some matches where I had devs
chatting with me or and then there were
some where I didn't have any jackal and
at all those instances right didn't have
a mic it like it totally worked well and
we were we still kind of orchestrated as
a strong team using that system and it's
so easy used like I was really blown
away like that so that it has really
good sort of nonverbal communication
yeah yes it's interesting respawns known
for taking mechanics that we take for
granted and making them really good for
example they originally put Titans in
titanfall and let you eject from them
just to make your battles longer yeah it
wasn't just a jet for the sake of a ject
it was here's how you actually have more
fun yeah so you know it sounds like
nonverbals one way are there other ways
you feel like this got the respawn touch
yeah totally
another thing would be it's so you just
like most battle Royales you can go down
right and then get a revive that's here
as well but the additional thing is that
and this happened once or twice was
really crazy where both my teammates
were down and I actually like got the
upper hand and eliminated the whole
squad that we were up against I revived
one of them but the other guy was like
permanently dead you can pick up his
banner and go to a respawn station and
he can come back into the game hmm
so there's yeah it's pretty cool so
there's a sense of like longevity with
play and arguably even time to kill is
felt way longer than any other battle
royale so you might actually have time
to say disengage or get away or yeah or
maybe even turn around on somebody yeah
for sure and or like just it's not
necessarily that you're gonna get killed
immediately so you can kind of take more
risks in a way I found myself like just
saying screw it and I'm gonna I'm gonna
see if I can get the upper hand in this
situation it was it was really
interesting how looks like right here
that's an LMG that I took so long to go
down and he's still not even dead yet
he's just he's crouching and when you're
crouched you can also throw up a shield
a limit amount of shield that you can
throw up to defend yourself and keep
alive right before you
permanently down there were some
abilities too so like yeah get into
abilities if yeah I think I saw some
footage of yours where you were face
shifting and doing some of the very
classic things in titanfall
right there's a handful of the tactical
abilities from titanfall to that have
transitioned over so the face shifting
is one and that's her it's it operates
on a cool-down that's her tactical
ability she can phase you know go into
the void right and then her ultimate is
essentially portal where you can
establish a intro portal and then like
another end location right to spit out -
that seemed really tricky to use but
again that's kind of like I want to say
the endgame is getting a really great
grip and understanding of all these
abilities and working with your team so
we're here I'm actually playing as a
lifeline which is like the medic she has
a drone that will heal at me and anyone
on my team and then her ultimate is a
care package that comes down and we'll
have some high-level gear which was
pretty cool another one that was like
from tyne fault too was the his name is
Mirage and he has the hologram he can
his ability is like create a hologram
and then his ultimate is basically spawn
like I want to say like half-a-dozen
Holograms of himself the other thing
here is you see that high-level gear
there the the armor it's an executioner
that's this level 4 gear level 4 gear
has it like a perk and this perk refills
my shield if I perform an execution so
that's pretty neat - you have some like
really interesting gear that you can
pick up
so overall I don't know is this just
gonna tie you over until titanfall 3
whenever that is or like what what's
what's the big hook on this game how do
you feel overall about another Battle
Royale game entering I mean I loved
respawn yeah
is this a game that you see having a you
know like a long tail yeah I I kind of
that's where I kind of get conflicted
because on one hand I think it feels
really great you know you look at
something like pub G right that had kind
of arguably shaky launch as it's not
perfect this game is super polished we
know respawn can do a shooter really
well it feels just like that menu and
you why I think is top-notch you know
you could argue that like blackout from
Call of Duty that menu was kind of
tedious mmm here was was it gets right
down to the to the core of like just
accessibility and an entry level is just
like so quick where like if you were
noticing there were some X's on ammo
types it just fly out says hey you got
an alternator and an LMG this ammo this
scope will work from don't pick it up
hmm so you can you like understand like
I got the menu so much easier and as
someone who is also really familiar with
tine fall these are all the same weapons
from titanfall so I could that's very
approachable because that's part of I
think the learning curve with a lot of
BR games is like knowing what you're
picking up and here it's very quick so
that being said I think something that
will will maybe result in my fall off is
so it's free to play
it's the cosmetics all of the perk ret
progression in this game is cosmetic
basis in a way granted you can get
everything naturally in game it'll
obviously take more time with their
currency system so you know it there is
no pay to win but there's just something
about the loot and and the cosmetics
that just doesn't do it for me I think
it kind of dials back into that
whimsical like colorful colorful style
choices that like I don't I don't have
any attachment to and that's kind of the
only thing going is like looking you
know looking cool having a cool-looking
gun that's that's more or less the
progression because you know you're kind
of given everything
front ultimately though this game is is
really fun and I had a really great time
and I think I think playing with friends
will do it for me as far as it'll get me
playing but again how long for is
debatable I guess awesome well thanks
Rob when when is apex Legends out its
out which is crazy to think that they've
had this you know in the bag for two
years since 2017 when like pub G was
like getting hot is when they took
inspiration and wanted to do something
of their own but yeah two years has been
in the making I'm fascinated at at how
it hasn't been leaked or anything like
that
platforms Xbox one PC and ps4 well
awesome
you heard it here apex legends it's a
battle royale game from respawn in the
titanfall universe and it's out now yeah
thanks Rob thank you
very nice